okay here it comes this is you can smell
you can smell the tactics here
yep hold on let me test the wind yeah
coming from the East yeah that's a
tactic and you can definitely tell
there's some tactics coming here I mean
you can just feel the heat especially
with the time he had two seconds there
two seconds
he wants to pick up the other room
that's right yeah the bishop is hanging
on A6 and now the bishop is hanging on
C3 what is happening and the queen takes
C2 is a threat he has to play something
like or two F1 or queen D1 but
something maybe to F1 because uh Queen
takes C2 is a real threat right now you
can uh if you think you want to play
something else
it says great for beer D2 backward moves
are always the toughest right and he
found it just keeping everything under
control and prank gets his other Rook
now into the game and nihal jumps to
this bishop attacking the pawn in front
of the king about to praise this move
but apparently the the uh you see it
earn the question mark there it's
somehow not the right choice although it
did look extremely extremely strong and
very very dangerous for black to handle
this is going to be in Practical terms I
think very difficult for Prague to
defend uh because on on seconds I think
creating threats is just so much easier
than responding to them precisely and it
looks like his father his last move just
now was a mistake yeah I don't quite
know how maybe we can attack The Rook
with the other bishop and that's quite
strong but uh yeah as you can see nihal
just uh drags the bishop all the way
back uh and that's a large part of his
Advantage with it as I said there will
be a lot whoa
96 very very interesting he clearly
prepared this when he was bringing the
bishop back I I don't know if that
sacrifices that that great objectively
but I think it's it's great practically
uh because it feels so good this bishop
now yeah
white has two Bishops there covering
during all possible squares on the board
and as you can see despite being a piece
down white is in in very very good shape
and you can even continue slowly as well
sort of slowly with this spawn move just
creating this very obvious threat of the
pawn Avalanche in the center uh it's
going to be very very difficult for
black to play this correctly
I like how Prague is holding himself
together problem is the time here the
time is definitely the issue for nehal
if he is if he makes one mistake here it
is going to the side of the game in fact
but this bishop is such a monster the
king is not is very weak for black yeah
but E5 coming queen D6 all the I mean
open game and yeah I mean I have a piece
but you know that piece is on A6 right
now has to make a move 15 seconds to go
Niha has to make a move and he is about
to make a move but in nine seconds eight
seven E5
I saw Queen D6 but what happens on Queen
B6 or maybe take by E5 E6 oh my goodness
Queen B6 just take on F6 or even better
Heat
and how black is that
is hanging
well at least she gets the piece back
and as soon as okay draw like yeah what
are you talking about and he says that
he has sees that this is incredible that
kind of shook his head there or maybe he
gives back his peace but now nihal
seemed to be in control here right extra
Pawn
King is safer looks great for him and he
hasn't Trust Quincy for picking up
another phone on A3 yes that's the truth
but we have to be careful also the
opponent that was a very strong one
Queen B2 is so annoying oh my goodness
it's so annoying Rook C2 which is played
Wing B1 Bishop F1 wow then check on them
Bishop f1co
wait what you can take Bishop first with
the queen and then C3 is a shot as you
said Discovery
Roxy one first which is play Rook C1 are
we gonna do you have a draw do you want
to draw bro you wanna draw oh
can't be a draw repeat repeat maybe he
puts the screen now back there wait
because if you cover with the
bishop it's just a lost right you're
losing them
okay
he plays it yeah I don't think uh that
Prague is going to take this because
that would lead to a lost end game for
him
and the play goes on 20 seconds maybe
King has to step aside from this open
diagonal
on push 17 seconds to go
a few moments later yeah
[Music]
right away is that a big change here
it's a big change here it's not a good
book is there a bishop sacrifice Bishop
G8 check some nasty things oh definitely
impossible
[Music]
um